from the guy who came straight out of
Compton and ended up in are we there yet
comes the most popular Black Friday
besides Black Friday and Rebecca Black's
Friday Friday before the release of
ride-along lace up your chucks for
another mid 90s classic you can't stop
quoting you got knocked out man on night
[ __ ] that I met in my back Creek
population that has no actual plot
whatsoever looking out after no
experience a movie without a single
white guy in the cast it's kind of like
a reverse motor brings me manchild cray
when he's fired for stealing from work
and his friend smokey gets caught
stealing weed they'll make things right
by stealing money this guy stole from
someone else it's kind of like Robin
Hood if he stole from the poor and gave
it to a guy names big worth something
one experience of film that's like a
spike Lee joint but with fewer morals
and more actual joys prepare to learn
more practical lessons like get high I'm
gonna get you hot again fight dirty
and don't get catfished but most
importantly get high man ain't in wrong
smoking weed clean your mouth watch Ice
Cube paved the way for Ludacris 50 cent
and LL Cool J as the first good rapper
to suck at acting anyway what's she
doing up ceramic and watch Chris Tucker
and the role that launched him into
rush-hour stardom and post rush-hour
obscurity seriously what the hell
happened to Chris Tucker get ready to
laugh at a film that would be super
offensive if it were written by a white
guy featuring Asian stereotypes Latino
stereotypes and of course black
stereotypes I want to eat some dumb
chitlin I love pink t just cool a hey
you know I want some kool-aid but you
don't have to be from the hood to love
Friday because this comedy speaks the
universal language of toilet humor hey
smokey back here tagging us hmm take a
look at that paper over they only kept
it he counted an M so if you love weed
90s comebacks we did that for your mama
and slamming metal doors
then thank God it's Friday and not the
terrible sequels seriously those are
like Madea bad not a new year thank God
you gotta let me go ah wait I take it
back
no story tall Kevin Hart left eye Lopes
Sabretooth crackhead bah Michael Clarke
Duncan damn
number two dad and Ice Cube Friday yo I
love it when they gave Ice Cube an ice
cube so you could watch Ice Cube pick up
ice cubes ice cube hey screen junkies
fans before we're bored to death by
award season
tell us what oscar-winning movie you'd
like to see an honest trailer of next
and while you're at it please subscribe
to kakakaka combo breaker earth fire
wind water heart all the signal ladies I
keep my mind on my money
bunny on my mind finger on the trigger
and hand on my 9 I ate his liver with
some fava beans and a nice Chianti